N
ORDER TO ATTEND THE GAMES.
A SHOCKING MOVE BY TENNIS STAR,
NAOMI OSAKA.
ON MONDAY, SHE ANNOUNCED SHE IS
WITHDRAWING FROM THE FRENCH
OPEN.
THIS COMES AFTER SHE WAS FINED
$15,000 FOR SKIPPING A NEWS
CONFERENCE AFTER HER FIRST
MATCH.
OSAKA SAID, LAST WEEK, SHE
WOULD NOT PARTICIPATE IN MEDIA
EVENTS, CITING MENTAL HEALTH
CONCERNS.
IN A STATEMENT ON TWITTER, SHE
SAYS THAT IN PART, THE MOVE IS
THE BEST THING FOR THE
TOURNAMENT, AND HER WELL-BEING.
ONE OF THE ENCORE RIVAL, SERENA
WILLIAMS, OFFERED HER WORDS OF
SUPPORT.
>> I FEEL FOR NAOMI, AND I WISH
I COULD GIVE HER A HUG.
I KNOW WHAT IT IS LIKE.
>> JOINING ME NOW, A MAN WHO
KNOWS THE PRESSURES OF
PROFESSIONAL TENNIS QUITE WELL.
PAT CASH, OR RETIRED CHAMPION,
WINNING WIMBLEDON IN THE 1987.
IT IS, INDEED, AN HONOR TO HAVE
YOU WITH US.
>> THANK YOU.
>> SO, I DO WANT TO ASK YOUR
REACTION TO NAOMI OSAKA
QUITTING THE FRENCH OPEN, OVER
HER REFUSAL TO PARTICIPATE IN
NEWS CONFERENCES, BECAUSE OF
HER OWN MENTAL HEALTH CONCERNS.
>> IT IS WITH MASSIVE BOUTS OF
DEPRESSION, I'M HERE IN PARIS,
I'VE BEEN ON THE TOUR FOR 5 AND
A HALF MONTHS, AND WITH CHINA'S
NUMBER ONE PLAYER.
SHE'S PLAYING TODAY.
I HAVE A GREAT UNDERSTANDING OF
THE PRESSURES THAT ARE INVOLVED,
AND I AM 100% BEHIND WHAT SHE
HAS DONE.
I KNOW IT IS PART OF PRESS
CONFERENCES, AND PLAYERS GET
THE BIG MONEY, THAT'S WHERE
THEY GET THE BIG SPONSORSHIP,
BUT WE ARE LOCKED IN THIS HOTEL,
WHERE IN A BUBBLE, WEEK AFTER
WEEK, WE ARE GETTING TESTS, WE
GET THE TEST TO ARRIVE, WE GET
TESTED EVERY 4 DAYS, AND I
THINK OF THE GOVERNING BODIES
REALLY THINK THAT THIS IS A
SURPRISE FOR A PLAYER, TO HAVE
A MENTAL BREAKDOWN, AND DESPITE
MENTAL ISSUES, THEY ARE FOOLING
THEMSELVES.
I'M SURPRISED IT HASN'T
HAPPENED SOONER, AND IT WILL
HAPPEN AGAIN.
I THINK, CERTAINLY, IT'S AN
ONGOING, PASSIONATE ABOUT.
THE IT IS THE SPORTS TOUR THAT
ARE PARTICULARLY POOR, THE AND
THEY ARE TRYING TO GET THE
TOURNAMENTS GOING.
I UNDERSTAND THAT SOME MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES IS SLIPPING BY,
AND WE UNDERSTAND, I'M 100%
BEHIND WHAT SHE'S DONE.
SHE NEEDS TO LOOK AFTER
HERSELF.
IN ONE INSANE WORLD DO THEY
THINK A YOUNG GIRL HAS COME OUT
AND SAID, I WANT TO HAVE THE,
SHOES I DON'T WANT TO DO PRESS
CONFERENCES, AND THEN FIND HER
$15,000 BECAUSE INSTEAD OF
TALKING TO HER AND SAYING,
LISTEN, CAN WE DO THE PRESS
CONFERENCES THE WAY YOU WANT TO
DO THEM?
HOW CAN WE HELP YOU?
INSTEAD, THEY FIND HER, FORCED
HER TO SAY, WELL, I WON'T PLAY
THIS TOURNAMENT AGAIN.
IT'S A TRAGEDY, BUT IT ISN'T
FOR ME, BEING ON THE 2 ARE
ALMOST 6 MONTHS NOW, IT IS NO
SURPRISE THAT THIS HAS
HAPPENED.
IT WILL PROBABLY HAPPEN AGAIN.
>> AND OSAKA, SHE REALLY HAS
PUT IN, IN A BOLD WAY, THE
SPOTLIGHT ON THE SITUATION.
AT LEAST, IT OPEN THIS UP FOR
DEBATE TO DISCUSS THIS.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN IN TERMS OF
WHAT TENNIS AUTHORITIES SHOULD
BE DOING, GOING FORWARD?
HOW THEY NEED TO DEAL WITH THIS?
THEY MUST LOSE A LOT OF GREAT
PLAYERS BECAUSE NOT EVERYONE IS
ABLE TO GET IN FRONT OF THE
MEDIA, AND TALK TO THE MEDIA,
TO ANSWER SO MANY OF THESE
QUESTIONS.
NAOMI OSAKA, REALLY, HAS QUITE
CLEARLY LAID THIS OUT FOR THE
WORLD TO SEE.
>> IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO
SEE HOW THEY GRAND SLAMS WILL
REACT TO THIS.
WHETHER THEY WILL FIND HER A
LOT, OR NOT.
FIND HER, I THINK, WOULD BE A
BAD MOVE.
IT'S HITTING HARD ON HER, AND
THIS WOULD JUST SHOVE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES UNDERGROUND EVEN
FURTHER.
THE I THINK IT IS AN
INTERESTING SITUATION HERE, FOR
THE ENTIRE WORLD, BECAUSE
EVERYONE IN LOCKDOWN HAVE BEEN
NOT USED TO, AND THEIR NORMAL
PEOPLE, WHO DO EXTREME THINGS
WITH THEIR BODIES IN THEIR
TENNIS LOOPS.
VERY MUCH, THEY ARE HUMANS, AND
IT IS WALKED OFF THE COURT AT
THE END OF MY CAREER BECAUSE I
COULDN'T HANDLE IT ANYMORE, AND
THEY SAID, WHAT DO WE DO ABOUT
THIS?
WILL THE SAY ARE INJURED.
I SAID, I'M FRIED, I CAN'T.
THEY WANT TO SAY, YOU'RE
INJURED, BECAUSE WE HAVE NO
PROTOCOL FOR THIS.
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S CHANGED
THAT MUCH IN 20 YEARS.
SO, I THINK IT'S A BIG ISSUE,
BUT OVERALL, IT IS AN ISSUE OF
PRESSURE, OF LOCKDOWNS, THAT
EVERYONE IN THE WORLD IS
FEELING.
TENNIS PLAYERS ARE JUST ANOTHER
PART OF THAT HORRIBLE SITUATION,
THEIR HANDS, BEING FORCED
OVERTIME.
>> LET'S SEE IF THERE IS ANY
CHANGES AS A RESULT OF THIS.
PAT CASH, AGAI